>> Now that we have the tiledJSON loaded, we need to parse it. So, let's take a
closer look at the structure of this file. There's a few things that should
interest you about this file, right away. First is the initial parameters
discussing the size of the tiles that this map expects. The second, is the
number of vertical and horizontal tiles used. For instance, the width parameter
here defines that this map is 100 tiles wide. Of course, the total size of the
map, in pixels, is width times tile width or 64 pixels per tile, given you 6400
pixels. Secondly, you'll notice that there's a section devoted to what atlases
this map uses, called tilesets. This section will list for each atlas, the image
location, given the absolute path from the editor as well as the width and the
height of the input images, any particular names or properties that you've
attached to the atlas, and most importantly firstgid, which we'll get into in a
minute while we're parsing our layer data. Finally, we have a separate section
of the JSON file devoted to the layers that you've defined. Now, each layer that
exists has a data element, which actually lists out a large, very large,
ludicrously large array of integer values that represent each tile that you've
placed on this layer. Of course, this layer also has other properties like the
height in number of tiles, as well as the opacity, and then any other
information like the name and whether or not this tile is visible. This type
parameter is also interesting, because tiled allows you to have both tilelayers
and object layers. Of course, this layer you're looking at is defined as a
tilelayer.